[Music]
huge fans of Breaking Bad as many people
are just an incredible show yeah I
really believe one of the greatest shows
ever and then I was delighted when I
realized I got hooked on the show and
I'm watching it and then I realized that
you and I went to the same college and
graduated the same year same year and
never ran into each other I don't think
thank God yeah
no we didn't we didn't know each other
that you were probably in the really
cool smart clique no no no I was in the
like how did I get into this college
clique no no I I think we all felt like
we were in that clegg I was spent a lot
of my time at the at the comedy magazine
like there's a building that we had and
I just live there all the time yeah and
you were doing a lot of acting I
actually remembered hearing your name I
knew people that knew you and I would
hear your name and you you were in a
certain theatrical production where men
dresses women well yes Hasty Pudding yes
yes theater company so they carried it
was your choice alone they'd never done
it before and you insisted I gotta be a
chick I'm more comfortable in a dress
that's what you said apparently it you
know I don't know what standards they
had apparently none at all but yeah it
was all males and so some of us had to
play female character it's actually a
tradition that goes back
what 19th century yes long long time ago
and so we have a picture of you from a
production in college
I mean Oh
younger I was younger then we look good
yeah you know the right night everyone
which mean the right night glass of wine
if you're looking at yourself in the
mirror how did that hairy forearms a bit
much yeah you gotta make it you know
okay you claim it you claim this was all
just because of this so-called Hasty
Pudding Club but then not long ago
you're at comic-con dressed as Xena
Warrior Princess what's that all about
let's show the photo please
a whole new meaning the six-pack abs
right that's what everyone wants to see
I would not hit that by the way yeah
yeah well that's four week different
that's what finally you got look right
it's nomicon you know you do it with a
easy I'm showing it you doing it
comic-con people dressed up so I figured
Xena Warrior Princess yeah I con yeah
why not why not that's the choice I got
the body type for it
[Laughter]